ça s'annonce très bien pour la septième
édition cette année donc nous sommes
dans la dernière ligne droite les filles
sont en train de filles peaufiner donc
leur spectacle le show et puis elle se
prépare aussi mentalement parce que
c'est également une préparation mentale
notamment pour apprendre à gérer son
stress que ce que vous voulez démontrer
que la femme honda savent pas faire
société
c'est exactement ça on vous montrer
simplement qu'elle est ronde ronde
humains que nous sommes avant tout des
femmes et que voilà tout à fait nous
avons notre place dans la société que
nous n'avons pas besoin de se concentrer
uniquement sur la taille pour pouvoir
juger les gens et qu'il faut apprendre
avant tout à voir ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur
nous avons commencé par les sélections
donc nous avons rencontré les 19
candidates qui s'étaient inscrits
nous en avons obtenu 12 et qui ont
commencé au mois de mai leur préparation
entre temps nous avons deux candidates
qui ont abandonné
et donc aujourd'hui elles sont dix à
avoir suivi donc tout ce qui était un
atelier de préparation
la démarche aussi le développement
personnel qui est très important pour
notre concours puisque nous sommes face
à des femmes qui ne s'acceptent est pas
forcément telle qu'elle était et donc
également tout ce qui va être mise en
beauté maquillage relooking est aussi
communication sont toutes très bien et
c'est à peu près trois heures de
spectacle
et puis la délibération du jury elles
sont toutes motivées elles sont
stressées
mais je leur fais confiance je sais que
tout va bien se passer samedi
des associations des parents alors nous
avons sur principalement les proches des
candidates qui les accompagnent qui les
encourage
et puis nous avons aussi déjà depuis
quelques années les des personnes qui
nous suivent qui nous accompagnent qui
sont qui sont sensibles à la cause et
qui viennent donc chaque année même
s'ils ne connaissent pas forcément une
des candidates et qui viennent et puis
également des comités d'entreprise qui
n'hésitent pas à venir vers nous pour
participer à l'élection
alors cette élection entraînera une
proposition france
alors cette année j'espère qu'il y aura
une élection à laquelle nous pourrons
participer
c'était en 2018 nous n'avons pas pu y
aller parce que nous avons été prévenus
en retard en tout cas cette année nous
nous préparons déjà surtout
financièrement pour envoyer notre miss
représenter la martinique à l'élection
nationale
alors les anciennes et ben elles sont là
toujours elles sont comme je le redis
elles sont toujours mises de leur année
elle intègre le comité si elles le
souhaitent pour nous accompagner pour
surtout encadrer les filles donc par
exemple ma responsable artistique
aujourd'hui c'est la vision de 2014 la
responsable de communication c'est la
miss ronde 2015
donc voilà elles sont encore là elles
sont présentes elles accompagnent les
filles donc avec plaisir aux comptes
quand elles sont mieux placés que moi
pour pour conseiller et suivre les
filles